et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien bonjour bonjour c'est beaucoup
d'être avec futé du Nord vice-président
de l'Assemblée nationale vice-président
du rassemblement national et en étant
sans pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview avec la presse régionale que
vous connaissez bien c'est la Voix du
Nord évidemment bonjour monsieur
déclenché un 49 3 le 7e sur l'ensemble
du budget de la Sécurité sociale est-ce
que le rassemblement national va déposer
une notion de censure a priori nous
n'allons pas déposer une motion de
censure nous nous réservons la
possibilité toutefois de voter ce 49-3
c'est encore en arbitrage mais deux
choses d'abord la façon kelisabeth borne
de gouverner ou en tous les cas de de
gérer l'action du gouvernement un coup
de 49-3 me semble être
néfaste d'abord c'est à l'opposé de ce
qu'elle nous avait raconté pendant des
mois et des années la nouvelle méthode
on devait écouter on devait être dans
presque de la co-construction et puis
finalement on a une espèce de brutalité
alors brutalité qui existe que les
textes va nous permettre il utilise une
arme la première à le faire non mais
autant de fois si mais
je pense que donc ça va à l'opposé de ce
qu'on nous a raconté de ce qu'Elizabeth
borne nous a raconté ça dévoile une
véritable faiblesse de ce gouvernement
qui n'arrive pas qui ne réussit pas à
trouver des majorités car il ne réussit
pas à convaincre ni à donner les signes
à un certain nombre de groupes
parlementaires de la possibilité de
prendre en compte des propositions que
pourrait faire ces groupes donc je pense
que tout ça est une très mauvaise
méthode que tout ça démontre une
faiblesse du gouvernement et puis
ça ne peut pas durer indéfiniment pas la
France à coup de 49-3 ça ne marche pas
ainsi et puis
je ne dis pas qu'il va falloir dissoudre
ça c'est le président de la République
qui s'en occupera mais il est urgent que
ce gouvernement change de méthode
comprennent que le monde a changé en
fait il faut qu'il change de culture ils
n'ont qu'une majorité donc il faut
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
gagner à tous les coups
[Musique]
en plus c'était celle de brutaliser le
Parlement et de glisser un amendement ou
d'utiliser un 49-3 pour ceci c'est pas
acceptable donc par conséquent je pense
que ce gouvernement ne se rend pas
compte que au-delà des difficultés que
vivent les Français au quotidien s'il a
ajouté demain une réforme des retraites
jusqu'à 65 ans puisque c'est le but de
d'Emmanuel Macron et bien ça mettrait
probablement le pays dans des
difficultés sociales inimaginables et un
côté presque cruel j'allais dire dans
l'action de ce gouvernement on a
l'impression qu'ils disent aux Français
vous en avez avec le pouvoir d'achat
vous emballez avec la Ferté de l'énergie
vous en bavez avec l'insécurité et ben
on va vous rajouter une réforme des
retraites faut-il à ce point ne pas
comprendre finalement ne pas respecter
les français pour agir ainsi autre
actualité concernant les l'actualité
parlementaire pardon cette journée est
réservée aux textes proposés par par les
républicains il y a plusieurs textes que
proposer réforme des procédures des
étrangers retraite de base des
exploitants agricoles et juridictions
spécialisées dans les violences
intrafamiliales et ce que vous voterez
certains de ces textes oui on retrace
certaines de ces textes ce matin c'est
le texte sur les retraites des
agriculteurs nous allons le voter parce
que nous considérons que comme la France
a été un pays qui a vécu la
désindustrialisation le prochain plan
social c'est celui de l'agriculture dans
notre pays donc il faut soutenir notre
agriculture ça se fait pas uniquement à
travers évidemment les retraites des
agriculteurs même si ce texte nous
allons le soutenir ça se fait aussi à
travers la défense de notre agriculture
à travers le localisme à travers le
patriotisme économique mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que oui nous nous sommes
des gens qui ne sommes pas sectaires
nous considérons que lorsqu'un texte va
dans le bon sens nous le soutenons nous
l'avons déjà fait nous sommes prêts à le
refaire en ce qui concerne les soignants
par exemple la rue
posé la question niche parlementaire en
janvier vous nous confirmez que vous
reprocherez la réintégration des
soignants non vaccins je ne vous
confirme pas les choses aujourd'hui
c'est pas moi de je vous dis simplement
que c'est un texte auquel nous tenons
que c'est un texte que nous avons envie
de voir
aboutir que nous considérons que 12000
soignants aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
réintégrés alors que l'hôpital manque de
bras c'est un ensemble nous considérons
que partout en Europe les soignants qui
n'avaient pas été qui a été mis à pieds
ont été réintégrés qu'on ne peut pas
mettre à pied indéfiniment des gens pour
cette raison donc il y a une urgence
cette possibilité qui nous est offerte
on est en train de la regarder ben non
mais on considère qu'il y a cette
possibilité qui nous est offerte on est
en train de voir moi j'y suis à titre
personnel tout à fait une précision sur
le sur le texte j'ai cru comprendre que
le votre proposition de loi ne prévoyait
pas de protocoles sanitaire strict pour
remplacer l'obligation vaccinale et
aucun test donc vraiment il rentre comme
ça sans aucune autre forme de protocole
le texte si on devait le reprendre en
fait on reprendrait le texte qui était
celui déposé par la France insoumise et
dans l'état de la discussion il en était
donc nous pourrions reprendre celui-ci
mot pour mot c'est pour ça que nous
sommes en train d'en discuter parce que
dans votre proposition de loi paraît-il
vous proposiez
bien sûr c'est à dire que il puisse
toucher ce qui leur a été sucré si vous
me permettez de le dire ainsi voilà donc
on va voir dans notre niche sur des
textes de différentes natures il y aura
un texte sur la fiscalité locale moi je
porterai un texte pour
sur le mode de calcul notamment des
taxes ordures ménagères c'est un
engagement que nous avons pris et qui
affecte beaucoup de Français
dans notre pays la capacité à pouvoir
revoir le mode de calcul pour baisser le
coût de ramassage des ordures ménagères
qui est supporté par les Français donc
il fallait passer par la loi ça c'est un
texte sur la fiscalité il y aura
probablement un texte pouvoir d'achat un
texte sur du un texte sur du régalien on
va on est en train de réaliser sur
quelque chose qui concerne la sécurité
aux l'immigration il y aura probablement
ce volet là et puis probablement un
contexte ça a été dit sur les violences
faites aux femmes nous considérons aussi
que c'est une problématique importante
et nous sommes en train là encore de
finaliser tout ça donc c'est encore en
discussion mais voilà 4 5 textes c'est
encore en discussion différents sujets
mais des sujets qui touchent la vie
quotidienne des Français nous ce qu'on
veut c'est être efficace on veut pas
partir dans des délires comme la France
insoumise sur la corrida on veut des
choses très concrètes quand je vous dis
un texte sur le pouvoir d'achat ça peut
être aussi un texte lié au salaire vous
avez vu que la France insoumise a
totalement abandonné la possibilité de
faire passer un texte sur le SMIC à 1600
euros nous on veut des choses concrètes
qui touchent la vie des français on se
dit que si à la possibilité de passer
des textes il faut qu'il répercussions
dans la vie des français très rapidement
donc le pouvoir d'achat et les salaires
la réintégration des soignants les
violences faites aux femmes
la sécurité oui il y a la fiscalité
locale
est-ce que est-ce que vous craignez que
le au Parlement on se retrouve dans la
même situation l'impression que lors de
la niche de la France insoumise avec une
obstruction qui ne permet pas de faire
passer les textes mais la France
insoumise a très mal joué elle a
programmé des textes qu'elle a
déprogrammé au dernier moment pour
pouvoir mobiliser du temps pour des
sujets qui étaient au début la corrida
c'est un garage
elle a déprogrammé le SMIC elle a choisi
qu'on ne débatte pas l'augmentation du
SMIC pour qu'on parle de la corrida et à
la fin elle a finalement des programmes
et la corrida pour qu'on parle des
soignants et elle avait plus de temps
puisque nous sommes dans des procès elle
a mal géré sa niche parlementaire je
pense qu'avec moins de textes il y avait
une douzaine de textes pour pour la
France insoumise avec moins de textes il
y avait la possibilité d'aller au fond
et d'aller sur plusieurs sujets on va
essayer en tous les cas de faire ainsi
ça veut pas dire qu'on réussira sur tous
les sujets mais nous on veut et c'était
notre ligne de conduite on veut du
concret quand on a été missionné par nos
électeurs c'était pour ramener rapporter
des choses concrètes aux Français
un texte sur les salaires
une augmentation comme le texte
je vous ai indiqué que l'attaque sur la
fiscalité locale pour rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux Français il pourrait y avoir
un texte sur les salaires là encore pour
rendre du pouvoir d'achat et aux
Français ce sera pas l'augmentation du
SMIC je vous rappelle que la proposition
de Marine Le Pen c'est une augmentation
de 10 % de tous les salaires jusqu'à 3
fois le SMIC en échange d'un gel des
cotisations patronales ça c'est
l'engagement de Marine Le Pen on va voir
si on peut le faire vivre donc ce sera
ça
l'assemblée disait déplorer
l'obstruction parlementaire d'où qu'elle
vienne vous êtes d'accord oui mais
l'obstruction parlementaire
j'allais dire elle prend deux visages
vous avez le jeu parlementaire qu'on
connaît qui donne des moyens au
Parlement y compris je passais de faire
de l'obstruction en tous les cas de
ralentir des débats de bon ça ça existe
mais je veux dire c'est entre groupe
parlementaire et quelque part on peut
intellectuellement la comprendre on
utilise les moyens que nous donne les
règles de droit mais l'obstruction qui
vient du gouvernement pour empêcher des
oppositions c'est ce qu'on a vu la
semaine dernière c'est à dire qu'un
gouvernement qui reprend des amendements
des sous amendements pour bloquer le jeu
parlementaire et pour bloquer des
oppositions un jour de niche
c'est-à-dire le seul jour de l'année où
l'opposition peut mettre des textes au
vote ça c'est pas acceptable parce que
d'un côté vous avez le 49-3 donc Madame
borne dégaine le 49-3 tout bout de champ
de l'autre côté des jours de niche seul
jour de l'année où l'opposition peut
mettre des textes sur la table le
gouvernement les blocs un moment ce
n'est pas acceptable
que nous on avait on avait choisi
immédiatement de nous attaquer à la
question de l'antisémitisme qui
évidemment aujourd'hui est prégnant dans
notre pays avec des nouvelles formes
d'antisémitation
1 ce sujet nous intéresse et que deux il
y a de nouvelles formes d'antisémitisme
dans le pays et qui va falloir les
entendre et les combattre bon Sylvain
Maillard a souhaité reprendre la
présence de groupe on a trouvé un
terrain d'entente on sera évidemment
membre de ce groupe d'études et ont
participera aux travaux et du coup vous
présiderez
on a une douzaine de présidence non je
ne poserai pas le groupe sur leur pardon
mais le rassemblement national présidera
le groupe sur sur le vin nous
présiderons des groupes qui vont de
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
des stagiaires jusqu'à les prisons
jusqu'au prison pardon les territoires
en conversion la Camargue enfin il y a
beaucoup de sujets très importants nous
co-prisons des groupes avec d'autres
groupes notamment sur le cancer avec je
je crois le modem ou horizon ou le
groupe liotte qui est un groupe
indépendant donc nous avons aussi la
capacité à montrer qu'on peut travailler
avec d'autres personnes Renaissance a
choisi eux de compresser des groupes
avec la France insoumise ce qui me
laisse un peu interrogatif
plusieurs groupes d'études sont
Renaissance au président
national alors qu'ils vont travailler
avec la France insoumise bon c'est une
voilà c'est une variable assez originale
je rebondisse juste sur les prisons
quelques-uns de de vos collègues sont en
train de visiter les prisons est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à une à des
annonces du rassemblement national sur
sur les prisons à une proposition de loi
quelque chose bon alors deux choses
d'abord les groupes d'études en question
ce sont des groupes transpartisans qui
sont faits pour entendre des
socioprofessionnelles etc donc c'est pas
des groupes dans lesquels on prend des
positions après les groupes prennent
eux-mêmes des positions nous vous
connaissez notre notre positionnement
sur les prisons la nécessité de
revaloriser évidemment le personnel
pénitentiaire la nécessité de construire
jusqu'à 40000 places de prison
supplémentaires ça ce sont évidemment
les les considérations qui sont les
nôtres mais c'est une problématique qui
est importante dans notre pays que celle
du pénitentiaire d'accord que vous avez
obtenu oui hier la commission des lois
est jugée recevable votre demande
d'ouverture d'une commission d'enquête
alors excusez-moi c'est le libellé est
très long sur les ingérences politiques
économiques et financières depuis sans
étrangères visant à influencer ou
corrompre des relais d'opinion des
dirigeants ou des partis politiques
français c'est tout libellé et c'est ce
que reproche d'ailleurs un petit peu la
commission des lois à cette demande
d'ouverture de commission d'enquête
c'est que c'est très large presque trop
panoramique est-ce que vous comptez
rectifier un petit peu le tir nous on va
être précis Jean-Philippe Tanguy qui est
à l'origine de cette proposition va
animer cette commission l'idée c'est
quoi c'est de regarder si dans notre
pays il y a des ingérences étrangères
vis-à-vis de partis politiques alors
nous ça a de de balayer aussi des
soupçons qui sont deux avantages 1 on
mettra dans la lumière exactement ce que
on nous reproche de façon totalement
infondée et partisane sur la Russie on
verra on va mettre ça tout ça sur la
table et comme ça ceux qui ont des
choses à dire vont devoir venir les dire
sans pouvoir se masquer par des
sous-entendus ou par des attaques
par exemple il y avait un ancien
d'ambassadeur de France qui nous qui a
dit que le rassemblement national était
revenu avec des valises on va demander
et on va redemander auditionner de
Russie de France en Russie nous allons
lui demander de venir visiblement il
n'était pas très chaud pour aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce genre de
propos infamant et puis surtout ça va
nous permettre de voir est-ce que la
Chine Singère dans un certain nombre de
relations avec des partis politiques
françaises que les États-Unis à travers
d'autres relais ce sont ingérés ont des
relations avec d'autres partis
politiques est-ce que la majorité a des
relations avec des grands groupes
américains tout ça va être mis sur la
table ça permettra de faire la lumière
sur ce que chacun peut reprocher
peut-être à l'autre et en tous les cas
nous on est particulièrement content de
voir que notre travail que va mener avec
la finesse et la précision qu'on lui
connaît Jean-Philippe Tanguy et vient
nous permettra d'évacuer ses soupçons à
fond de notre candidats notamment
d'Emmanuel Macron être très large et
lorsque nous devrons solliciter
l'audition
d'une personnalité ou d'une autre nous
n'allons pas nous en empêcher nous
voulons aller au fond des choses et je
pense que là encore la démocratie
française a tout à gagner de cette
commission hier soir les députés ont
voté une résolution pour affirmer le
soutien total à l'Ukraine est condamné
le crime d'agression envers la Russie
les députés du rassemblement national ne
l'ont pas voté pourquoi mais parce que
cette résolution d'abord elle
rapprochait elle disait plusieurs choses
dans son texte un elle disait à
rapprocher à terme l'Ukraine de l'Union
européenne nous considérons que ce n'est
pas souhaitable et puis elle était très
en soutien de l'OTAN donc là aussi
encore c'est une différence manifeste si
vous voulez ce sont les résolutions
le fait de soutenir l'Ukraine euh c'est
une chose et je crois que nous sommes
clairs là-dessus profitez de cette
situation pour faire avancer l'OTAN pour
imaginer que l'Ukraine demain puisse
rentrer dans l'Union européenne c'est
une autre chose c'est un autre tiroir
qu'il y avait dans cette résolution donc
il ne fallait pas compter sur nous je
pense même que ça peut parasiter cette
résolution l'action de la France à
l'international et donc je crois que
c'était pas souhaitable
on assiste à un retour aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale votre collègue
député Grégoire de Fournas qui a été
donc sanctionné sanctionner début
novembre après avoir été accusé de
réflexion raciste
une sanction pour des propos racistes
d'ailleurs aucun propos n'a été qualifié
de ce style là non en Afrique c'est dans
l'hémicycle lors d'une intervention de
d'un député Carlos Martin bilongo de
elefi doit faire son retour à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui il
devrait prendre la parole sur les
pensions de retraite est-ce que c'est
une bonne chose
qui reviennent est-ce que je sais qu'à
un moment donné il avait été anticipé
peut-être qu'ils deviennent porte-parole
du rassemblement national ou pas été ça
ça avait été encore quelque chose qui
était sorti après cette affaire non non
a été sanctionné pour tumulte pas pour
propos raciste pour tumulte il a donc
subi sa sanction il reprend donc son
rôle de parlementaire de base et il va
pouvoir intervenir effectivement sur un
campement
est-ce qu'il y a une mise au point de
Marine Le Pen sur le groupe et sur les
sorties telles que celle-ci tel que ce
mot qu'il reprenne je crois qu'elle a
dit elle-même que effectivement on
pouvait faire preuve d'un peu de de
finesse dans un certain nombre de débats
et que créer du tumulte n'était
peut-être pas la meilleure le choix
qu'on avait fait nous en ce qui concerne
la discipline et l'image qu'on
souhaitait donner de notre groupe
maintenant il y a une proposition
politique derrière ça il y a il y a un
débat politique on doit avoir sur
l'immigration et si l'idée c'est de
bâillonner un député qui à travers un
propos probablement pas haut de gamme
mais veut simplement dire que nous
n'avons pas vocation à accueillir Océane
victime Viking et si l'idée c'est de le
bâillonner ça peut pas marcher parce
qu'elle Assemblée nationale on doit
pouvoir tout dire Emmanuel Macron il
faisait une visite d'État il déplore les
mesures économiques super agressives de
Joe Biden et il a l'alerte même cette
mite dilate massive aux entreprises
américaines pour fragmenter l'Occident
vous soutenez manuel Macron là dessus
les États-Unis sont des amis de la
France historiquement mais ils sont
aussi parfois des concurrentes et ils
sont aussi parfois sur certains enjeux
économiques des adversaires donc on doit
pouvoir entretenir avec les États-Unis
une relation qui soit exigeante on
dirait qu'Emmanuel Macron le découvre
quand les Américains font du patriotisme
économique ils défendent leurs intérêts
moi ça m'énerve ce qui nous en sommes
victimes mais moi j'aimerais que non
mais moi j'aimerais qu'on défende nos
intérêts qu'on fasse nous du patriotisme
économique on voit bien que les
États-Unis sont en train de profiter
de cette guerre de ce conflit armé en
Ukraine qui économiquement ce sont eux
qui en profitent mais nous l'avions dit
dès le début donc Emmanuel Macron un peu
le côté ce côté un peu naïf on dirait
Bécassine aux États-Unis enfin
sincèrement il découvre la poudre de
main quelles sont les enjeux de main sur
lesquels on a à être exigeant vis-à-vis
des États-Unis c'est aussi
l'intelligence économique la capacité
qu'on les Etats-Unis à pouvoir entrer
dans nos systèmes de données il y a des
choses sur lesquelles on doit être
exigeant vis-à-vis des États-Unis pas
être naïf et pas les laisser avancer bon
bah Emmanuel Macron on a le sentiment
qu'il découvre ça et que pour lui le
patriotisme économique est un gros mot
c'est le chemin que suivent les
États-Unis depuis bien longtemps c'est
pas depuis Biden qui font du patriotisme
économique Trump en faisait largement et
ses prédécesseurs aussi et bien moi
j'aimerais que plutôt qu'on dénonçage
chez le voisin plus et bien il faudrait
plutôt que Emmanuel Macron en face ici
du patriotisme économique qu'il défende
enfin les intérêts de la France Marine
Le Pen reprendra des des voyages à
l'international aux États-Unis on se
souvient qu'elle avait des contacts avec
le réseau de Donald Trump
reprendra des voyages à l'international
partout pas uniquement aux États-Unis et
probablement avec des gens qui seront un
peu plus étonnants peut-être que ce
qu'on peut attendre des dirigeants dans
le monde qu'on ne voit pas forcément
aujourd'hui dans l'actualité dont je
crois il est intéressant de suivre
l'action ne nous n'ayons aucun interdit
il y a des des pays qui avancent il y a
des pays qui ont des politiques
il faut nous préciser
oui il y a des pays qui développent par
exemple la patriotisme économique qui
fonctionne dans leur pays sera peut-être
intéressant d'aller voir ce qu'ils font
mais on a du temps devant nous dernière
question alors qui concerne le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais une enseignante en
philosophie là qui est en classe
préparatoire à Valenciennes a dû annuler
son voyage de classe à Calais auprès
d'une association d'aide aux migrants
après des menaces reçues alors des vont
être déposées par l'enseignante et le
rectorat le rassemblement national ou
même titre que le mouvement reconquête a
critiqué cette sortie et dénoncer je
cite une propagande pour l'immigration
vous soutenez cette dénonciation oui
parce que je pense que cet enseignante
elle agit en militante et elle agit pas
en éducatrice
[Musique]
une inclinaison qui fait qu'elle imagine
qu'une sortie dans un camp de migrants
et plus importante que transmettre un
savoir moi je pense qu'une enseignante
elle doit transmettre un savoir or aller
trimballer des gamins dans un centre de
migrants c'est à voir une prise de
position politique on a son sujet de
l'année un projet pédagogique
pluridisciplinaire j'insiste là-dessus
était exil et frontière allez voir ce
qui se passe à Calais n'est-il pas une
façon assez naturelle de comprendre la
question des frontières je crois que son
boulot n'est pas celui-ci et je crois
que si son cette thématique c'est exiles
les frontières elle n'est évidemment pas
thé à travers la restauration de
frontières nationales mais plutôt à
travers l'ouverture de notre pays à
l'ensemble du monde donc je pense que ça
veut dire par exemple est-ce qu'il y
aurait une contestation par exemple de
du fait qu'elle aille rencontrer des
associations d'aide aux Ukrainiens ça
vous aurait choqué la même manière moins
de politique dans l'éducation nationale
plus d'enseignements c'est ce qu'on
demande merci Julien leculé merci
beaucoup
du Nord les médecins en grêle c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup